okay
I catch my breath uh
going to convene today's public hearing
of the house special committee on child
care we will start with the Pledge of
Allegiance Representatives Paige you
okay let me get my uh as you can tell by
my exasperated breathing I was running
here
so let me get my calendar up for what
we're handling today
uh you know I feel like I run everywhere
um I should run more I probably wouldn't
uh
here we go
okay
all right so first up is we're going to
open the public hearing for SB 94.
um which is relative to residential
child care licensing of child care
institutions and agencies I believe we
have
okay
um excellent uh Senator if you want to
introduce the bill and afterwards if you
could fill out a pink card for me
I'm just so we have it
uh if you did I didn't make it to my
desk so I apologize either way we will
we will move on and not waste your time
but if you could just jot one down for
me when you leave before you leave
that'd be great
welcome to the special committee on
child care
good morning
um and good morning Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Sharon Carson and I have the
pleasure of representing Senate District
14 comprising the towns of Londonderry
Hudson and Auburn and I have for your
consideration this morning Senate Bill
94 which
see let me make sure I got this uh it
seeks to modify and add definitions to
daycare licensing it also modifies the
requirements for licensing renewal for
child care licensing this bill is at the
request of the Department of Health and
Human Services
um the department has requested changes
to RSA 170e in order to provide Clarity
to certain definitions change
definitions to better serve youth in
residential programs add Provisions to
clarify the child care uh excuse me the
child day care renewal of licenses to
add Provisions to rulemaking the process
creating the rules for the request of
waivers to minimum standards and to
provide for the investigation of
complaints at youth recreation programs
and the confidentiality of complaint
records Mr chairman recommendation
excuse me representatives from the
Department are here to provide a
detailed overview and to respond to
questions from the committee so I thank
you all for your time this morning and
again
thank you thank you Senator and um thank
you so much I I assume by your statement
you'll have DHHS answer the questions
yes um which was perfect finally said if
you're just toss me that pink card on
the way out the door yeah I will thank
you so much
um
next up uh so we have two people so uh
DHHS I believe is coming up so Melissa
Clement Doreen uh Shockey and
um Danielle I'm gonna can't read too
much uh white boys
um is there any objection to having the
three of them up at the same time since
they're all together
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the committee for the record my name is
Melissa Clement and I'm the chief of the
child care licensing unit in the
Department of Health and Human Services
so I'm here today to walk you through
what requests the department would like
to make and which is brought forth in
Senate bill 94.
um the this proposed legislation wants
to amend certain definitions to address
some inconsistencies between the
definition and to update others
for the part one the child daycare
licensing definitions the change that is
being requested on page one in lines two
through four and
I I didn't see the copy that was
presented here so I'm hoping that what I
printed off the internet is what you
what you have as well
um but it's part one page one lines two
through four
um we're requesting to change the
definition of
um child daycare caring for children
younger than three years of age instead
of calling it a childcare Nursery we
just wish to updates terminology to
infant and toddler program
um part two and three under day care
licensing license renewal
um this change adds the following to the
renewal process for a child daycare
licenses corrective action plans as part
of the additional information required
for a renewal application if the
department has conducted an inspection
and determined that the child daycare
agency is out of compliance with
licensing rules
um at the requirement that corrective
action plans are received prior to the
renewal of a child daycare license and a
new paragraph that allows the department
to renew a license without inspecting
the premises if the program is not
operating provided local fire and health
approvals have been completed as
required that's already part of the
application process this will ensure
that there is no delay in renewing
licenses for programs that do not
operate year round or are closed for
other unplanned reasons the department
will be required to complete an
inspection within 30 days of when the
program opens
and do you prefer that I read through
the whole thing or do you want to stop
section by section uh let's go Section
by section I think we've got my
preference then so all of it at once at
least my brain wouldn't be able to
handle all that so that's what yeah
um so are there any questions
for part two or three for the renewals
yes
represent McWilliams
thank you chair um and thank you very
much for bringing this bill
um just a question about the timeline
for the corrective action plan and then
of course receipt and acknowledgment and
approval of the corrective action plan
do we have some rules through gel car as
to how much time that can actually take
right now um there's actually
um statutes around that as well as and
obviously we incorporate those statutes
in our rules so there is um we need to
when once we set the correct the
statement of findings to the program
they have 21 days to return a corrective
action plan
um and then we approve it and get it
online okay yeah thank you you're
welcome
the corrective action plan but there's
one that's seven days right or five days
if it's uh was it like a mandatory
violation or something so
uh a it's
twin General if there's a directed
corrective action plan where the
department and that's defined in our
rules where we determine that there's a
imminent health and safety risk we can
request a direct a corrective action
plan and we ask those be returned within
seven days
that's also defined in rules
okay
is it should I proceed to part four okay
um part four residential care and child
placing agency licensing definitions so
this starts on page one line 27 and it
goes through Page four to line 31.
um I'm not going to go through line by
line I'll give an overview what that is
and then I'm happy to answer questions
um a change to the definition of child
is being requested under RSA 170e 25
Roman numeral one to read child means
any person under 21 years of age and the
changes or up to 22 years of age if the
person is receiving special education or
special education and related Services
as identified by the child School
District
this change is being requested to align
with
hb1513 which changed the definition of a
child with a disability to include
children between the ages of 3 and 21
inclusive
and permit special education students to
attend school up to their 22nd birthday
the department licenses residential
child care agencies for youth under 21
years of age
currently residential programs serve
youth placed in their programs through
school districts so this change would
permit the department to license the
residential programs for these students
up to 21 years of age it's being done
um other changes are reorganization of
the definitions of Child Care Agency as
types of child care agencies were added
to the statute over time rather than
including them under RSA 170e
25 Roman numeral two they became their
own definition
these changes move all child care
agencies under the Child Care Agency
definition and do not change the
definition themselves
this includes the definition of child
care institution and independent living
home as a result there are changes to
the enumeration throughout along with
elimination of the Redundant term Child
Care institution and other definitions
when the term Child Care Agency is used
as child care institution will now be a
type of Child Care Agency
um and in addition the definition of
experiential Wilderness facility has
been removed as a type of Child Care
Agency
and I'm happy to pause there to answer
any questions on those definitions
representative
um just going back to lines one through
three I know it's really hard to predict
the future
um but if there's any way that we could
reword this instead of saying up to 22
years of age
simply up to the age aloud if the person
is receiving special education or
special education related Services
understanding that that number may
change in the future and it's kind of a
pain for the legislature to have to
revisit and redo a bill and vote on both
houses and have the governor sign it
perhaps it could be a little bit looser
with the terminology would that be
acceptable to the members of the
committee instead of locking it in at
um so the only thing I would ask is if
it points to a certain
um other statute where wherever that age
is being determined
because up to the age a lot if we don't
say a lot where so if we're pointing to
that that would provide Clarity for us
as well
would your intention there uh
representative to be to have it up to
Loud by rule or
just can you add a little clear I I mean
you know I kind of I generally
philosophically agree with what you just
said so I just want to make sure we're
on the same page I think Allowed by rule
as opposed to Allowed by Statute simply
because the statute process is kind of
difficult and we would expect that there
may be some revisiting in the future
depending on research and understanding
so when my thought thought to that is
that we are changing this based on
Department of Education policy so I
guess I would want to specify which rule
our rules or their rule
whoever's the subject matter actually
okay on special education and related
services so that's improving to bed
they're the subject matter expert I
think that's what we want to go with
okay I'm just trying to prevent
additional committee hearings and build
changes on something that we could be a
little more vague on to allow it to flow
okay
I representative page
uh could you provide me with a little
bit more context on the experiential
Wilderness facility piece and you know
why that struck why that was problematic
um a better understanding sure
absolutely thank you for the question
um it's we haven't licensed a program
under that provision in a very long time
we haven't had the need to we've had
programs who
operated more of a camp type situation
and we've been able to do that under our
existing rules and statutes without
having to have a separate rule set or a
separate provision for that type of
um agency so we're just trying to it
wasn't being used and we are we have had
the ability to do that under our current
rules
sure
further questions from the committee
okay we can proceed okay thank you
all right so the next section is part
five which is residential care and child
placing agency rule making consultation
so this starts on page four line 32-34
we are requesting to add to the
rulemaking provision the process for
requesting waivers to minimum standards
for our child residential facilities
this is currently part of all other
facility licensing and DHHS and this is
the one area that we don't have that
provision in statute so we're looking to
have that alignment and have that
representative McWilliams
so how is that currently handled
if there's a complaint
um so it's a waiver process so it's um
currently with the residential programs
they are required to abide by our rules
and there isn't the ability to waive
them for residential 24-hour programs So
currently we don't have the ability to
grant them waivers so we want to have
them to have that ability as any as like
anybody else thank you sure
can you elaborate on that we you can't
grant them waivers why wouldn't we just
allow it by Statute that's what I'm
trying to do that's what you're trying
to do yes I'm trying to add that to
their statute it's not currently there
okay so if we if we have this in there
we don't have to issue waivers at all
no I'm sorry if
um by adding this ability to it's under
the rulemaking process so by adding it
the ability to have us create rules that
allow for waivers we'll be able to add
that to a rule then they'll be able to
apply for them our rule making statute
under residential Child Care programs
does not have the ability for waivers so
that's what we want to add so we can add
it to our rules
okay so I could follow I'm just kind of
confused why we wouldn't just make it
statutes where they could do whatever he
was trying to waive or issue a waiver
for I don't like waivers I've I don't
like the idea of waivers if it's either
needs to exist or doesn't exist right
like waivers need to be the
exception not the default so I guess
that's my question I think we're not I
don't even know if you're understanding
me is if we're allowing you to issue a
waiver why wouldn't we just allow
whatever it is you're trying to issue
the waiver forward to exist in statute
period
so our the waivers are for the waivers
and rules so if we have a certain rule
that for whatever the certain
circumstances of the program doesn't fit
what we have in rule we can then our
value that fits the intent of the rules
so that they can do what they need to do
to operate and then we can grant a
waiver to the rule they have that
ability I understand so you can't
currently grant them for these
facilities at all this gives you more
flexibility inside of it for a cart
block if there's exceptions okay all
right all right we can move on sorry I
was a little confused there for a second
but you got me back all right no my
apologies if it wasn't clear so I'm glad
we're there thank you for the
clarification all right so under part
six Recreation camp licensing
definitions this is on page four line 35
through page five line two
we're requesting a change to the
definition of recreation Camp by
changing boys and girls to children and
then to add that the definition does not
apply to group day care centers and
preschool programs as defined under RSA
170 E2 so that would be our child day
care statute which will create Clarity
for the public and the department
regarding which type of license and
entity is required to obtain to provide
you with a little context there child
care licensing
was given the authority to license camps
starting 2020 it was currently licensed
under the Department of Environmental
Services since for a really long time
and they you know it wasn't really the
right place for it so they've brought it
over to us as we've been working through
the camp licensing and obviously the
first year we had it was the first big
year of covid there weren't a lot of
camps operating so we've been learning
over the past few Summers about what
that looks like we're finding it
increasingly challenging to identify if
someone says hey I want to run this
program for children and this is what
we're going to be doing they could fit
under either statute and we're trying to
make sure there's a little more clarity
as to which statute they need to follow
so we're exempting their ability to have
a camp license if they fit the
definition of our group daycare or
preschool programs as currently defined
and then if I move along to part seven
that's okay under Recreation camp
licensing confidentiality of an
investigations we're requesting a new
section to align with other licensed
facilities in the department regarding
the conducting of Investigations of
complaints received for non-compliance
of Licensing standards and the
maintaining of confidentiality of the
records compiled during investigations
by the department when we adopted the
camp program from the Department of
Environmental Services they didn't have
any provisions for investigation of
complaints in the confidentiality of
those investigations so we're looking to
align what we do with our child care and
other licensed facility programming in
the department and bringing camp
licensing
and that's it for my testimony and I'm
happy to take any additional questions
thank you um just wanted to ask for
clarity for the purposes of notes so
um you were saying you were finding that
many camp programs could fit under
either the camp definition or the
daycare definition and so now you're
saying anything that goes that can fit
under daycare should go under that
otherwise Camp okay yes thank you yes
thank you for the question the clarity
further questions from the committee
all right sing none thank you okay thank
you very much
uh no is there anyone else wishing to
speak to Senate Bill 94
um if not representative Neil can you
grab me the blue sheet for Senate I know
it's kind of awkward going to walk
around but I gotta have to I'm supposed
okay thank you
okay uh there was no one signed in
either uh in favor or a post Senate bill
94. um
uh with that and seeing no other
speakers I'm going to close the public
hearing on Senate Bill 94. uh the
committee will stand in recess until 10
30 at which point we will take up Senate
bill
um 170.
trust but verify that statement yep uh
the house special committee on child
care I'm going to open the public
hearing on SB Senate Bill 170
um which title is I'm supposed to read
the title
um let's hold on
there it is thank you uh relative to
small group day Child Care Centers uh
representative Perkins KOA is here to
introduce the Bill thank you Senator
excuse me I apologize I'm not used to
the Senators coming to us
um it makes you feel any better senator
in election law they just send Grant
bosse so um they don't give me that they
don't give me the Dignity of their
presence so
um Senator it's good to see you thank
you welcome to the house special
committee on Child Care yes thank you
for having me
um
members of the committee this morning
for the record I'm Senator Rebecca
Perkins quoka representing district 21
which is Portsmouth and several Seacoast
communities here to introduce SB 170
legislation to increase our child care
capacity in New Hampshire
sp170 would create a new regulatory
category of daycare that allows
licensing for 6 to 12 children outside
of a residential setting and listening
to our small businesses they said that
finding a location to start a new child
care business was their biggest barrier
and this bill is intended to be
responsive to that need
in addition SB 170 clarifies the law to
be consistent with fire code regulation
concerning the presence of school-aged
children on site at a licensed facility
we understand this to be a needed change
the fire marshal can speak to and we
have also made
um some changes in the sentence process
to make sure that um as amended the bill
reflected the fact that our goal of
everyone's goal is to increase capacity
for child care in the state and make
sure that we're not um
changing any existing capacity that's on
site
sp170 is the result of collaborative
working group that includes providers
the child care licensing licensing unit
and the Fire Marshal's Office this group
met throughout last fall to bring you
the piece of legislation in front of you
today
currently and I don't need to tell this
committee this I suppose but 46 percent
of people live in child care deserts
where there are three children waiting
for every one available space this bill
introduces a critical Solution by
providing Child Care opportunities to 29
more children freeing up parents to join
the workforce a style of small group
daycare also provides the flexibility
and enrollment that is typical of a
home-based daycare
by creating new available commercial
spaces for our child care businesses it
would help break the single biggest
barrier to child care location
oh
um more Working Families will now have
available convenient options when they
pursue returning to work
as a mother to a one and a half and
three and a half year old I know the
Korean County of child care
um and it's it's very helpful to all of
us in our economy for our Working
Families to be able to make sure that
our children are well cared for while we
go about our days
so
um with bipartisan support coming out of
the Senate and no fiscal impact My Hope
Is that this bill will be a positive
step forward to support our Working
Families and that you can support and
ought to pass recommendation today I'm
happy to support any question excellent
other questions from the committee
uh oh yes representative McWilliams
you were involved in these working
need some
I'm seeing this holiday section that's
been struck twice from the bill can you
just give us a little bit of background
as to why they can't flex and take kids
on uh school vacation or school holidays
um I'm representative respectfully I am
going to defer that but I there's a
bunch of people here and I know they can
speak in detail to that thank you so
much Senator no problem for the
questions from the committee
okay sing them thank you Senator thank
um
let's hear from the public first that's
what I'd like to do that
um
Jennifer
League
oh geez I can't read your name I'm sorry
Jennifer gin Jin you want to come up
geez I can tell you can tell I'm not
make sure you press that silver button
in front of you otherwise they can't
to write the bill
um so I am very knowledgeable of most of
the details of this at this point
um we had a really great group working
with us throughout the year of subject
matter experts on this bill so a lot of
time and effort has gone into it
um
so I own a place to grow in Brentwood
um and I worked with Senator Coco
writing and researching SB 170
increasing Child Care capacity for New
Hampshire the bill before you represents
a simple and efficient way for the state
to allow for child care capacity
building simply by capitalizing on all
allowable spaces permitted by the fire
codes this simple bill has the ability
to increase capacity by 29 in the state
of New Hampshire amassing that you
support SB 170 with a recommendation of
ought to pass
I began writing sv-170 last year in
response to a gap I found in child care
licensing rules and fire codes that
could provide an opportunity to create a
new category for child care John
Randolph from Harmony Homes was seeking
a pathway to incorporate both affordable
housing and on-site Child Care into
their business model
I worked collaboratively drafting the
bill language with Melissa Clement of
child care licensing Mitch Katie from
the Fire Marshal's office building
inspectors Architects and many
stakeholders in the Child Care community
the bill is presented would not only
preserve the existing capacity in
licensed family care but will serve to
create a new opportunity to increase
capacity for child care in New Hampshire
through the creation of small centers by
adding Child Care opportunities for 12
children in each new center created the
small centers that will be created out
of the adoption of the bill would be
beneficial in Workforce housing units
rural areas the hospitality industry and
for businesses like Harmony Homes and
Carriage Hill Assisted Living
there is an absolute need to preserve
every child care space we have in the
state and the need to provide
opportunities for growth as there are
over 2 000 children we are unable to
serve which means 29 of our Workforce is
unable to return to work I am asking
that you support SB 170 with a
will you be taking questions
are there like are there questions from
the committee
so small child care centers it's defined
by NFPA 101 so the fire marshal could
actually speak a little bit more clearly
to that
okay for the question I representative
claims
so I just want to ask the same question
I asked before about this um striking up
to three children attending a full day
school program may be cared for up to
five hours per day
on school days and all day during school
holidays is sort of this Flex time thing
where you could take extra kids but
we're removing it can you just give a
little background as to what happened
there so again that's something the fire
marshal can probably speak to a little
bit more clearly than me but the way the
fire codes are written to my
understanding is that the capacity is
just for the number of children not for
the ages of the children and the variety
of children that are allowed so by
strictly going to 12 you would still
have the capacity to take up to 12
children during holidays vacations
weekend so you would still be able to do
that okay so it's a fire code thing
thank you very much further questions
from the committee
I'm saying none thank you Jen I'm sorry
I like spaced we had like an hour-long
conversation on Zoom like it's not like
I don't know who you are
um
Cal from Early Learning New Hampshire we
are a Statewide non-profit
um who uh represent Child Care programs
and the families they serve and um we're
in support of this bill and when this
bill was created as Jen mentioned she
really worked with a lot of people and
we did find a few glitches in the very
beginning and people were very
responsive and um we co-host with nine
other organizations twice a month the
zoom calls with the Child Care community
and back in the day before Zoom we used
to have about 20 people who could show
up to monthly meetings now we have twice
a month meetings and there's over a
hundred every every time so people can't
get out as you know very well they can't
get out of the building they couldn't
even before the pandemic now they really
can't so so
um Jen came to those meetings and talked
about the bill and um so we're very
supportive of this bill
uh will you be taking questions yes I
will thank you any questions from the
committee
arrested represent Warner
thank you thank you
um Miss Cal
so
even though the Senate did I thought a
good amendment to allow family child
care providers who now are caring for
the extra children right after school
and on holidays potentially as time goes
by they'll be limited and do we have any
idea how many spaces we are losing
because of this action because it seems
like this is a really important piece
for families if your younger child goes
to a family child care provider and your
older child can go after school for an
hour or two and so potentially I think
there is going to be a loss of capacity
thank you for that question I think
that's something we'll want to watch one
of the things we did do
um based on the concern that current
providers if there hadn't been a
grandfathering current providers would
have been able to serve fewer after
school kids so even though they were
grandfathered there's the point of these
people then you know there'll be other
people coming in who can't do what they
used to do in terms of watching after
school kids I don't have the stats on
how many children are would be affected
by that but it is very common for small
sites family me to have the baby there
the preschooler there in the after
school child there and it is great for
families
so I think we should watch that
further questions from the committee
thank you so much
um last up DHHS Melissa Clement I assume
it's the same thing as before we just
bring you up and if we need others we
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee
um for the record I'm Melissa Clement
I'm the chief of the child care
licensing unit for the Department of
Health and Human Services and
um Senate Bill 170
um this legislation creates a new
category which you've heard before but
I'll you know reiterate creates a new
category of care for children up to 12
children in a location other than a
provider's home we currently do not have
rules around that type of category of
care and so those rules will be
developed for this category and specific
to the needs of a small child care
setting in a setting other than the
child provider's home
um in addition this legislation aligns
the statute with the life safety codes
capacities for Family Daycare homes and
family group daycare homes for Family
Day Care the definition changes the
capacity to six children and for family
group daycare that changes the capacity
to 12 children current statute permits
the addition of school-aged children
three for family child care and five for
family group child care which is in
conflict with the Life Safety Code for
these categories of care
these changes will only impact new
programs licensed on or after the
effective date of these rules unless the
program is licensed prior to the
enactment Do Not renew or their license
becomes no longer valid
and the new category of care will create
more opportunities for child care
programs with 12 or fewer children to
operate in locations outside of a
proprietor's home which will potentially
increase the number of child care
programs operating which create more
child care options for families we find
this is particularly true in smaller
towns they don't have the ability to
have a program that is large 25 50
because they can't either they don't
have enough staff or they don't have
enough children to fund them so having a
smaller category of care with different
um operational costs would be easier
underneath that having a small category
and I will proactively answer some of
the questions I heard before but feel
free to ask some more so we currently
have
um about for family family group Child
Care programs we have 122 and
representative walner I heard you're
concerned about what may happen in the
future
it I don't see it impacting a family
Child Care Program as much so the
individual provider because they will be
able to be licensed at Family group and
still have the nine children so that
they'll just be a family group instead
of family child care so that option
won't be lost for those it's I could
potentially see I to your point about in
the future people will not be able to
have a family group that has more than
12. there are many towns currently
though that do not allow for that
because of zoning so you also have that
restriction as well or you have the life
safety codes they're not approving them
and we have experts in the room who can
speak to potentially why but family
group right now there are not many that
are being approved more than 12 because
their towns won't allow it or their life
safety code inspector limits them to 12
because of the building and what they
have in their building to meet the Life
Safety Code the Life Safety Code
increases once you get to 13 and above
so that's
my answer to that and I'm happy to
answer any additional questions yes
representative Warner so how many family
group providers do we have family group
we currently have 69 69 but we only have
all right but to clarify two we only
have
um with those that are more than 12 out
of that 69 is only 38.
for family groups that are carrying more
than 12.
and a further question yes
um
so what the department intends to do is
that if I'm at home and I'm taking care
of six children and I have a license for
six
you're saying that now I can be a family
group provider and have a license for
knowing aren't there other
rules that govern
what a family child care provider needs
to have in place to be go from 6 to 12.
yes so when they are caring for a family
group
when a family group provider is working
alone so there's only one provider
currently the way the rule reads is that
they can care for six preschool children
plus three school-aged children and that
rule would remain so they would still
they'd be licensed as family group
as a licenses family group when they're
carrying when they only have one
provider that rule is still is there now
and we intend to keep that
so they'll be in compliance with Life
Safety Code with the capacity and then
also they'll be meeting our rule okay so
um places for children will be in the
family group the 38 or potentially more
family group
they'll be they'll always now be limited
to 12. right yes and and as I mentioned
there were I'm not sure how many I could
try to see if I could find out how many
have come on board recently
that have been approved for more than 12
because like I said there are many towns
or Life Safety go where they're not able
to meet that standard anyway so they are
being limited to 12 through their local
requirements not necessarily through
license
as well but that could give us some
additional Clarity on the issue as well
okay thank you you're welcome so to
follow up on what representative Wallen
are saying in a world in which they
could their local rules allowed them to
have more than 12. this this would
basically prohibit that
yes and it has to do with the Life
Safety Code
as well so
um
somebody from the Fire Marshal's office
here okay well yes um we'll let you
finish up Miss Clement before we do that
but I think you guys aren't signed up to
speak but I would like you to come up
and I think answer some of these
questions
representative McWilliams
I know you've already had a whole bunch
of
bunch of disgusting and gotten in your
heads so this this 12 number and I know
the Fire Marshal's Office will speak a
little bit more to it there's a
potential for maybe 38 of these
facilities who could have had more than
12 that will now be locked to 12. is
there a potential for exemption no so
there's a grandfather clause in this
amendment yes so anyone who's currently
licensed under it's
on page one on line 26 applicability the
provisions of the Zac shall apply to
programs licensed on or after the
effective date
so it's moving forward those who are
currently licensed will keep that
license and remain licensed the way they
are
but for a new facility that could
potentially fall into what's currently
happening with those 38 or so they
wouldn't be able to go past 12 after the
date of this is an act yes correct all
right thank you you're welcome
for the questions from the committee
thank you and I'm just coming you're
hanging around right I assume yes we may
I get the feeling you may be coming back
I'm here for the duration yes
um I don't have any we do we do we're
not having else time to speak I would
like the Fire Marshal's Office to come
forward I think there are some questions
we'd like to hear from you guys is that
the sentiment of committee when they
haven't fill out the card I think I
think we'd like we'd like that if we
could
and uh
two chair thing I'm Sean to Mary I'm the
State Farm Marshall I'm going to let
Deputy Mitch Katie speak a little bit
he's been integrally involved in the
subcommittee work
um so I can back him up but I just let
him where he's been more involved I'll
let him talk to that so we are very
supportive of this process and the
Village today but I'll let him to the
questions good morning Mr chairman
members of the committee uh like the
Marshall said my name is Mitch Katie the
deputy State Fire Marshal I oversee the
building safety and Construction Group
for the Marshal's office and we've been
working very closely with Jen and her
working group on
aligning some of these discussions that
we've been having to kind of clean up
some of the discrepancies in DHHS rule
as they relate to the state fire code to
answer your question there's
um the state adopts the 2018 edition of
The Life Safety Code which is
enforceable uh across the state and
within that document there's rules
relative to daycare occupancies and
within those daycare occupancies on the
Life Safety Code there's numbers of
occupants that are set based upon that
code so when we start talking about no
more than 12
those those numbers come out of the
state fire code as it sits so if you
were to go to uh commuting and open up a
new daycare and you wanted to have 15 to
20 kids per se you'd have to follow
different requirements under the state
fire code than you would if you only
wanted to have six kids or five kids or
whatever that number may be so 12 is
kind of that magic threshold that we
look at under the fire code for where
different requirements fall so again
depending on the number of children that
are going to be
occupying this daycare determines the no
the the level of protection relative to
building construction fire protection
features and so on that would need to be
present in that area if you will because
again the point of this bill is to get
these smaller daycares out of the home
environment into a more commercial
setting if you will which the fire code
allows under the definition of
um these day cares it's generally within
a dwelling unit for some of these
smaller uh daycares however part of the
the point of this working group has been
to expand that
ability to open up some of these smaller
daycares of less than 12 in some of your
questions from the committee I certainly
um okay I'll start off
um
so I think just kind of looking around I
think there is some
heartburn that the idea of that we would
be grandfathering in some and then
disallowing futures
um so I guess kind of get to the
philosophical question here which is if
it's not safe to have more than 12 why
are we grandfathering it
um and if that is the case right I mean
that's a legitimate question if it's not
safe why we're doing it
um and then if the I guess the follow-up
to that would be couldn't we write in
something into this bill I didn't really
want to amend this bill but if if we do
amend it could we write something in to
where you know over 12 when it allow
when when allowed when it meets the
standards of the fire cup
could we put something in there to kill
that because I think there's some
concern about that 12 number
so just uh representative the the way
the fire code is written it breaks down
the
the daycares into a new daycare so to
say you were going to build a brand new
daycare at your home your residence and
you wanted to build today you'd have to
meet a certain set of standards that are
established under the state fire code
on the flip side of that there is
Provisions for what they call existing
daycares that have been in existence
they've been up they've been operating
and you know we would articulate that if
there's more than 12 children in this
daycare that they would have to meet the
requirements under the state fire code
for that occupancy
um so as far as the fire code goes the
fire code makes Provisions for a new
daycare and an existing daycare again
that number is the number of occupants
is where they would have to fall in
terms of what those requirements would
representatively Simoni
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so the 2018 Life
Safety Code currently says
that over 12
is unsafe
can you can you explain what the 2018
thank you for the question
um so there the the threshold of 12 is
the where
you look at applying different safety
features to those occupancies so if
there's a if there's a daycare currently
that's operating with I'll use an
arbitrary number of 18. with 18 children
That Daycare in theory should be meeting
the requirements of the Life Safety Code
for a daycare occupancy that has more
than 12 kids 12 12 children so the the
rules we're not necessarily saying one's
more safe or less safe what we're saying
is that there's the the numbers dictate
what level of protection that the fire
code requires
thank you
just follow
thank you I I'm just trying to wrap my
head around this to make sure that the
kids are safe so
if the new code requirements have to be
met by new
child care facilities
why is it that the existing Child Care
Facilities aren't required to come up to
those standards upon renewal of
licensure
there's the way that the codes are
written is that they take account for
upgrades and safety features upgrades in
technology and so on so forth It's
understanding that
sometimes it becomes
is a balance between practicality and
Effectiveness so that when
you go and you say you're going to
upgrade your license the way the fire
code is designed we wouldn't mandate
that they get brought up to those new
new construction standards if you will
only just by nature of re-licensing and
so on though the way the consensus
documents are written or the codes are
written is that they've been established
to take into account that some of the
building features
may not be perfect but they're still
safe under the guise of the code and
that they're still safe under as we've
adopted it here under state law and you
know as the state fire code so that it's
not a I don't want to call it a
diminished level of safety because
there's a there's an established level
of safety for these existing daycares if
these daycares have been inspected
they've been re-licensed every you know
on their their light re-licensing
schedule you know part of that process
is to have the fire department or the
the building inspector the fire
inspector whoever's in charge in that
Community go out establish what's there
compare it to what the state fire code
says that is that we've established as a
safe level of
um
uh building features that are provided
to make sure that that building is code
compliant for that use to make sure that
the kids are safe
does that make sense thank you
further questions from the committee
full disclosure I'm an architect
so let's talk about some of the like
must-have safety features right so when
we're talking about 12 being the cut off
okay if we have like a basement of a
raised Ranch where we're putting
children and they're a home daycare but
maybe they want to take more than 12. I
understand you're going to probably need
two means of egress right to make sure
that everybody can get out if there's a
fire in one corner of the basement they
can get out two different Corners two
different directions it's a life safety
thing and I totally get that and that
makes sense right but some of these
other requirements may not completely
make sense for an existing facility to
make them upgrade and add a second means
of egress as the code gets stricter and
stricter and I know this is also based
on occupancy for the square footage of
the space provided right so if we have a
larger space you can probably have more
kids if you have a smaller footprint
then you're just limited for occupancy
for the number of kids allowed within
that basement facility right correct
we're on the same page on this okay so I
think the the fairness piece that we're
grappling with is a committee is that if
we're going to grandfather under
previous codes some of these facilities
but we're not going to allow new
facilities to meet those requirements
then it seems like there are some things
that are squishy that can be allowable
to get through
right that are not necessarily two means
of egress because that's an egregious
thing but something that's a little bit
and thank you for the question and I I
want to make sure we answer it so just
if any time you know your two means of
egress you know you you have a basement
of a ranch a raised Ranch if you will
you know that those the sleeping rooms
would require a primary mean to be
aggressive secondary means of Escape if
there's no sprinkler system in the
building so on so forth there's a number
of a host of requirements that would be
put into place the thought process being
and and
understanding that if these existing
buildings let's say again they were
licensed for 20 15 to 20 kids whatever
that number may be more than 12. the
fire department should have been
inspecting that building to the
appropriate occupancy chapter or the
appropriate occupancy section of the
daycare chapter to begin with because
the fire code doesn't dictate licensing
so when the fire inspector or the
building inspector whoever that
Authority having jurisdiction is went
out however many years ago to look at
this space and say we want to put 15
children in this area they should have
been looking at it under the
prescriptive guise of the state fire
code to make sure that those
requirements were put into place
at the time of the original application
and then again those things those
inspections have continued during the
license renewal process to ensure that
any safeguards that would have been had
to have been adjusted or manipulated or
done so as part of the re-licensing
yes of course so just so I understand
so it sounds like there really aren't
things that are acceptable as
grandfathered but these annual
inspections you are keeping up with the
current fire code right so you're
following 2018 even if it was licensed
10 years ago and things that may have
changed you're still going to check
those changes and there may be some
modifications required to the facility
to keep up with the new codes but we're
still going to allow those say 15 or 18
kids instead of 12 for the facility
that's been operating and successfully
having that number of children as long
as they've successfully passed their
inspections their subsequent
instructions and and those you know I
don't
those
changes that have been made from code
cycle to code cycle to code cycle
under the existing use
are
again I don't have the exact changes in
front of me but they tend to be minimal
in that sense that you know one year you
have
an established daycare and then three
years later the fire department makes
you put a sprinkler system in those
those kind of changes don't occur from
code Edition to code Edition in the
existing section of the code unless
those will all get vetted out through
the board of Fire Control through the
legislative process upon adoption of the
state fire code itself so in these
particular in these particular cases
again if you have a daycare that's been
in operation since the mid-2000s
as the code changes those inspections
have been done to those changes and any
updates to that facility that would have
had to have been done however small they
may be would in theory have been done
along the way so that when we get to
this discussion that now that we're
looking at
again there's not necessarily A
grandfathering as far as the fire code
is concerned they have to meet the
existing requirements of That Daycare
chapter and in theory those should have
been caught any changes to that should
have been caught along the way during
the subsequent re-licensing inspections
by the fire department but just a second
representative Williams
um is anyone here from the Senate to
introduce Senate Bill 221 currently
there is um if it's right with you I'm
going to recess this hearing I'm going
to allow the senator to introduce SB 221
just to respect their time and we're
going to go right back into this hearing
so I'm going to recess I'm going to
recess SB 170 uh for the purpose of
introduction of SB 221 to respect the
Senator's time and we're going to come
right back what I will do is I'll the
center will introduce SB 221 I will
immediately recess it we'll come right
foreign
thank you so I'm opening the hearing on
SB 221 for the purpose of introduction
good morning uh chair Barry and members
of the special committee on child care
it's great to be here this morning
um the room was full so I decided to
wait in the hall you know like abiding
since the Fire Marshals here in
particular where we should we should
probably like pay attention to occupancy
um so uh I come before you this morning
to introduce Senate Bill 221 and it's an
amended format so let me just talk you
through just a little bit about where
why we
introduced this in the first initially
and where we're at now so this bill as
proposed as enabling legislation that
would allow municipalities to adopt a
property tax exception again this is for
local legislative bodies if they so
choose for child care agencies the
purpose of this I mean this is an all
hands on deck situation and trying to
find solutions to the child care
Workforce issue and the City of Lebanon
working with
oh it's over 470 businesses throughout
the Upper Valley so you're going to see
it's a study committee now but I just
when it came out the door it was in this
in in this format that's that's not what
it says wait a minute so we should be
looking at establishing a study
committee to examine Day Care access and
affordability and if you look at the
what's it in section three on duties it
talks about number three the feasibility
and cost of an optional Municipal
property tax exception for child day
care agencies so that's why so it's
still a study committee absolutely okay
I started it with this
is our initial proposal and then because
often with study committees and I'm
clear like we there's plenty of them and
we have to be very judicious about
putting these together but there were
more questions and there were answers
and this is a different opportunity a
different type of solution at least the
municipal tax exemption but it led to
questions between the difference of
charitable organizations and not for
profits and that grew into questions
about regulations around Workforce
related as you can see in here Workforce
related license restrictions it could
limit Child Care Workforce limit access
to local daycare options so the
committee and consultation with the
leadership of the committee I agreed
that there were more issues than just
this and we all again agreed that we
have to be looking at things differently
and trying to come up with different
solutions I want to say in the initial
version I'm just really proud of the
fact that local businesses really banded
together with government and tried to
figure you know like how can we address
this differently and that's how this all
started so that's the background on how
I got to how I how I initially got in
front of a
from the Senate on well what I
introduced in the Senate and how it's
grown over time because there are
questions that we still um need to we
need to resolve charitable organizations
not all agencies are not-for-profit
Licensing and Regulatory restrictions
around operating a local daycare
including Workforce so I agreed that we
should we should uh embark on a study on
this and that's why I'm before you today
and I'm happy to answer any questions
you have and I hope that I can find your
support to move forward with this thank
you okay are there brief questions on
this bill
okay as thing done thank you so much uh
I'm going to recess SB 221 uh the public
hearing we're going to go right back
into this uh we we recessed the previous
one to allow you to introduce to respect
your time thank you you're welcome I I
have sat out for hours waiting for
probability introduce so I I I respect
people's time um so we are it's not that
we're disregarding your bill we're just
coming back
we're coming back to it all right thank
you we're gonna so I'm gonna reopen the
um public hearing on SB 170 uh relative
to small group day centers I believe the
deputy Fire Marshal was in the middle of
a uh definitely not a debate with
representative McWilliams put a question
and answer period yeah and I apologize
for interrupting represent McWilliams I
hope you understand my reasoning behind
thank you because I really want to be
fair and I'm concerned about fairness
okay that's really the underlying
concern here
so the number 12 right 7 to 12 children
I feel like that number 12 has in the
past been more than 12 because the
requirements are met for inspections and
whatever the additional building
components that are necessary to reach
15 or 18 whatever that number is in a
home child care
and so
the number 12 just looking at this from
someone who's coming at this from the
outside hasn't been attending your
working sessions I feel like that is
limiting for future new facilities
within a home
but it doesn't have to be because the
code may actually allow 15 or 18. we are
just deciding in statute the 12 is the
cap
is that your take on this or is there
more to it
um thank you for the question 12 is
again 12 that number 12 comes directly
out of the state fire code so that it
wasn't an arbitrary number that the
committee developed it was aligning
these discussions with when we look at
capacity you know you know
that the numbers align with the
prescriptive requirements under the
state fire code so when we start talking
about existing daycares that have been
licensed for
more than 12.
understanding that they
in the perfect world have already met
the requirements that they would need to
meet for those
um the the under the prescriptive fire
code we've run into situations I've run
into it personally in the past where you
have a daycare that has
10 children and they want to go to 15
they want to go to 20. then they would
have to go through the process to make
sure that they're meeting the
appropriate requirements under the state
fire code in the State Building Code so
if that's if that's a business model
that they choose to go down in in that
endeavor and they want to expand beyond
that 12 then they would have to meet the
prescriptive requirements of the state
fire code and the State Building Code as
they sit
well so talk to me about the process for
doing that do we have a separate
category for 13 to X so the way the fire
code is written it's up to 12 uh and
then more than 12 falls under a daycare
occupancy under the fire code so
three to six is
Family Day Care
six seven to twelve becomes group
daycare and then more than 12 becomes a
daycare center if you will or under the
fire code and I'm transcribing those
terms but it's three to six seven to
twelve and more than 12. so depending on
the number of children that the
proprietor wants to take care of they
would fall into one of those groups and
if they wanted to move between the
groups they would have to meet the
prescriptive requirements
that are necessary so again that magic
number of 12 if you will has been
established under the state fire code it
wasn't just an arbitrary number we use
that number deliberately understanding
that the requirements change once you
get over that more than 12.
okay so I'm feeling like this
grandfather piece is not applicable and
the folks that have more than 12 should
just go through the process of applying
to become a daycare facility straight
out
my understanding is that the again the
the fire code discussion is part of this
is aligning the language in the fire
code with the language in DHHS rules uh
one thing that we've noticed is that
when we have conversations with fire
inspectors or fire officials the
terminology becomes a little bit messy
and one of the things that we've worked
very hard to do with this group is clean
up that language and again I can't I'm
not going to speak to the licensing side
of it but to be able to
align the licensing language with the
fire code language so that when you have
a fire inspector in XYZ community that
they're saying the same thing is that is
found under the fire code because
sometimes okay that the you know the
fire inspector can say well you're only
you know you can only have 12 but the
license allows for 15. well no you're
limited by the 12 under the fire code so
there's this bill hopes to clean that
clean up some of those discrepancies so
that those don't become issues and it
just becomes a point of confusion that
they're able to be worked through on
with discussion but if we can clean it
up now it just makes it that much easier
moving forward and uh
so thank you I just I think that we
would want to strike the um
this actual not apply to programs
already licensed before the effective
date of this act I think we would want
to strike that In fairness so that those
programs that are already licensed but
have more than 12 need to go and get
licensed under the 13 plus category
that's enough for me to speak but we'll
have to have that that's uh we'll have
to have that conversation in our duly
noticed work schedule uh work session
which starts in three minutes
um allegedly
um representative walner
thank you so you refer often to the
state fire code could this have been
handled differently and actually have
changed the number
in the state fire code
from
a family Child Care Group family child
care being 12 plus the after school
could that have been done as opposed to
the way it's being done anything's
possible
there is a process to modify the state
fire code
um the decision the discussions that
were had were to bring
the Fire Marshal's Office on board with
these discussions as a technical
resource to ensure that as these the
language of this bill was written that
it didn't create a conflict with the
state fire code or the State Building
Code so that we were providing insight
and information based upon the way that
the code was prescriptively written
yes so if I have 12 I have a license for
um
younger than probably younger than six
that are in my home and I'm allowed to
five
now if I don't have a license that I'm
going to decide to have a 12 and I want
to have five school-aged children after
school I have to go now I can I can get
a license but I have to go to the
center-based license is that correct
I'm not familiar with the licensing
terms yeah yeah
which means that I fall into a category
that is more of a
it
more regulated and it's a large it can
go up to 100 children when so it goes
from 12 to
whatever thank you for your question
initially when you initially went from
your 12 plus 5 your your occupancy your
building should have been inspected to
17. the fire department or the the
inspecting agencies never should have
inspected it to 12 they should have
inspected it to that 17 if you will and
the requirements that would have been
set forth your your property would
already meet the requirements for having
that number of student children in that
occupancy
so it wouldn't it's you were you would
have been inspected at 17 the the plus
five the plus three whatever that
discussion is for licensing purposes is
irrelevant to the fire code as as the
fire code says 13 or more or more than
12. you meet these requirements and in
this particular case you would have been
you would have met the requirements for
your 17.
so how much difference is there between
the requirements for 12 and the
requirements for this center-based
license that could go up to a hundred
I can I don't have them specifically I I
don't it would be a disservice to try
and repeat them verbatim without going
through the document and providing those
differences if that's something the
committee would like we can certainly
work on putting that together
uh thank you would you say it's
significant
potentially depending on it it depends
right as an architect it depends it
um
representative representation thank you
um just for clarity for for General fire
code not necessarily for daycare but is
that sort of the same step like from 12
has one thing and then it goes up to 100
or are there sort of gradations normally
for medium occupancies
it depends on the occupancy
um you know it depends on the use of the
space uh it depends on what is occurring
is it a is it a business use is it a
restaurant is it a nightclub is it a
daycare is it a school so the fire code
the state fire code is full of occupancy
limits in terms of numbers if if there's
this many numbers you go here if there's
this many people you go here so to say a
small medium or large if you will is
it it's not necessarily applicable to
all occupancies but again when we look
at occupancies as a as a whole
the number of people that you can put
into them obviously becomes Paramount to
making sure that the proper safety
features are put in place
oh
so you might have a situation where you
know for an occupancy of 50 there's kind
of a medium or medium features different
features than it would be for an
occupancy of 100 or for 200. so a an
Excel I'll give you an example if you
have a business if you will that has 30
people in it you may only have to have
one door out of that space if you have a
business that has 100 people you may
need two doors out of that space and
where those doors are located is based
upon how long it takes the people to get
from point A to point B to the outside
so it
for the questions for the deputy fire
marshal or Deputy
further questions
okay uh thank you
um can we make sure you fill out a pink
card for me
um I'm gonna recess
um
this hearing real quickly I'm going to
open up our work session because I have
to put to a question to the committee uh
before noon
um
in order to meet the scheduling rules of
the house if we wanted to meet next week
I need to notice the bills that we are
currently hearing because we haven't
closed our public hearing yet
um
[Music]
into our committee assistant by noon so
the reason I'm I'm opening up a work
session to ask this question is if we
wanted to introduce a non-germaine
Amendment obviously you need to be
relative to child care please don't play
games
um I we would need to we would need
another week to schedule that
non-germaine hearing because obviously
it's not drafted
um so I guess I'm just doing a quick
pulse of the committee of do you want me
to schedule the executive session for
these bills that to one of which we have
heard to which we are currently hearing
uh next week or do you want me to put it
into two weeks if it's in two weeks I
don't need to send an email but if it's
next week I need to send the email in
the next uh 40 minutes
so I just kind of wanted to survey the
group
okay all right so next week would
eliminate the possibility of any
non-germain Amendment so if we get into
work session and we find something that
we review
um that we've heard from our let's see
the three four times we have met that we
wish to introduce on to a bill that
would effectively eliminate that option
unless we were to notice the executive
session uh and then recess it which we
could do
so is that the preference
it's it's a question anybody can chime
in it's a working session it's a it's a
preference question
I just need to know because I if I don't
do it by noon then it's it's the
questions it's no longer a question now
we're doing it in two weeks yes
representative
so are we
that's my intention for the for the work
session I didn't expect us to run um I
thought this was I thought I did not
expect our turnout given our historic uh
attendance so I didn't expect this to go
as long which I'm very excited about uh
but is now creating a unique problem so
I think makes sense for us as a
committee to work next week and if we
feel like we want to do an exact let's
notice the exec at the end of the work
session for next week and if we open and
shut the exact we do that but it gives
us the opportunity to at least work
through some of these and maybe we get
there maybe we don't okay so I think
that that's probably the most logical
approach that's that's fine by me and
that's definitely an opportunity it
obviously gives you a little bit shorter
notice
um for if we have to do a follow-up but
as long as we're on the same page being
transparent about it I don't I don't
want to be accused of like pulling a
fast one just these are these are the
rules that they gave me
um anybody else have any questions
comments concerns about that and if
that's the case I will just notice this
for 10 a.m next Wednesday for the
exactly then we'll go right back into
our hearing
um okay without objection I'll do that
um so we're gonna we're gonna finish up
the I'm going to close recess our work
session which we'll come back to
um a lot of recesses uh and we're going
to reopen the public hearing on SB 170
which I get the feeling I'm about to
close
um is anyone else I don't have any more
cards on SB 170 does anyone else wish to
speak anyone present wish to speak to SP
170 anyone have any other questions we
do have a work session so we have the
opportunity to grab DHHS for the State
Fire Marshal again shall you choose
um all right hearing no up yes
representative Nelson
thank you Mr chair I just have a
question I'm not sure whom it would be
directed towards but
um if somebody could speak to the
potential impact of us not allowing
um let's grab that in the work session
okay I think
um okay um representative can you grab
me that blue sheet for SB 170
so I can formally close the double
recessed hearing don't worry here
we're operating like the scent doesn't
it feel nice you know with the beautiful
people on the other side of the wall you
get to just open close move left right
up down uh there was one person signed
in in support not speaking uh with that
I will close the public hearing on SB
170 and I will resume the public hearing
on SB 221 it has been introduced by the
bill sponsor
um
um that wants to introduce that so we
will hear from
um next up will be Devin Quinn
from Concord
Devin Quinn are you still here oh there
you are I apologize I didn't see you
walking on the back
welcome to the house special committee
okay
sorry about that I'm Devin Quinn from
the New Hampshire women's Foundation
um we supported SB 221 as it was written
originally and we continued to support
it now as a study committee
um uh we are specifically interested of
course in child care as a women's issue
because uh women are more likely than uh
women with children are more likely to
leave the workforce or reduce hours than
men or fathers and single women
particularly have a harder time at their
median income affording child care then
married couples so for Access and
affordability reasons we're interested
in Child Care Solutions
um but this committee certainly knows
about a child care issue um and so this
isn't a study committee on child care as
an issue but on specific clever Creative
Solutions
specifically Senator Apprentice
mentioned lines 12 through 16.
um for regulatory burdens licensing
restrictions and the feasibility and
costs of optional useful tax credits
the women's Foundation we run a program
called women run and it's the only
non-partisan program training and
encouraging women to run for office at
the local level of state and so we get a
lot of
women who are Democrats Republicans
Independents or not politically
Affiliated at all who just want to serve
their community and they're often the
women who are closest to the issue of
child care as people struggling to find
Child Care themselves their friends
their neighbors they intimately know the
child care facilities in their area and
they're looking for municipal
solutions to the problem they're seeing
in their community and so the original
bill would have been an opportunity for
uh women at the local level to be able
to provide some type of solution knowing
that this needs a little bit more study
the women's Foundation is really
supportive and wants to be as helpful as
possible in whatever this committee
would need in terms of data or you know
an audit of certain towns or cities in
order to get that information for you to
consider it so we wanted to
say our support for the committee and be
as helpful as possible
are we retaining questions sure are
there questions from the committee
saying none thank you so much
um next up Jackie Cowell from Concord
and early learning New Hampshire
welcome back
thank you Mr chair and hi again I'm
Jackie Cowell from Early Learning New
Hampshire and I simply support sb221 as
a study committee and again
um I'm glad it's around affordability
accessibility I'm hoping Workforce which
is the number one thing affecting
affordability and accessibility right
now is part of it the other thing I
would suggest is adding the
legislatively enacted New Hampshire
Child Care advisory Council to the list
and perhaps some other providers as well
I'm sure the committee will bring folks
in but that I think would be a good
addition to the list
thank you uh will you be taking
questions yes are there questions from
the committee sorry can you just repeat
that I will so it's the legislatively
enacted
New Hampshire Child Care advisory
Council
and so adding a representative yeah I
want to like the chair or their designee
thank you
all right um
further questions I guess it was really
good question uh the question from the
committee
all right seeing none thank you um next
up Amanda Sears from Concord New
Hampshire representing campaign for
and thank you chair and thank you
members of the committee my name is
Amanda Sears I'm the director of the
campaign for family-friendly economy
here in New Hampshire
um I wanted to speak in support of this
bill I do think you know at some level
the creation of this committee
um is to do the same thing that this
bill seeks to do what is different is it
adds a senator so it creates another
body where the Senate is also working to
think about Creative Solutions I mean I
know that it would be a different
different body so I'm not saying just as
a senator um but it would be another way
for this for you know members of the
State House of Representatives to work
together with the Senate to create
buy-in on legislative policy moving
forward to address the child care crisis
just I don't want to I know you've all
been learning a lot about what's what's
address what's feeding into this but
availability affordability and
sustainability are the big pillars of
what we're trying to address here
um and particularly the workforce crisis
just I wanted to add one little tidbit
of information because I think that what
elevates this from
um you know at the uh budget hearings I
was here for the Senate and the house
I've heard so much about the workforce
crisis and I think everywhere you go
that's what you'll hear in New Hampshire
uh the women's Workforce participation
has taken a huge hit since the pandemic
a 3.2 percent drop in women's labor
force participation since 2019 which is
enormous in terms of the amount of
that's about about 19 000 women who are
not in the workforce compared to who
were in the workforce in 2019 and for
every sector of the economy that is uh
desperate for people to be working for
them those 19 000 women who are no
longer participating in the economy
would really help and so I just wanted
to take that add that into the
conversation that not only is the child
care Workforce struggling but so was the
rest of the country the state's
Workforce and that elevating the issue
of child care for Solutions is a really
important piece of that thank you
will you be taking questions of course
are there questions from the committee
representative McWilliams
committing an email and some of that
data that you just shared I think that
would be really helpful for us moving
forward sure of course thank you further
questions
saying none thank you are there any
other members of the public wishing to
speak to Senate Bill 221 hearing none
representative O'Neill can you one more
foreign
no one was signed up uh who did not
speak either in favor or opposed to this
bill
um with that I will be closing the
public hearing on Senate Bill 221 and I
will be reopening our work session so
work session
let me kind of give where an overview of
where we're at uh where we're going so
obviously the committee gets determined
kind of where we're going uh and what we
have in front of us
um
we're gonna meet at least one more time
um obviously I just noticed that by the
way that's why I was being so rude to
the presenter um I was noticing our
executive session so I apologize to the
um to the testifier on that but we will
meeting next week at 10 A.M we'll have a
10 a.m uh noticed work session and then
we'll start executing bills at 10 15.
obviously we can roll that exact back
that gives us at least 15 minutes where
we're going to have to talk to each
other
um
so
um the way I look at the world as of
today as we've had I believe we've met
three or four times
um we're gonna do one more session in
the field most likely in Greater
Manchester
um I know that uh big thanks to
representative Paige for shooting us up
to Conway um it would be wrong to not do
one at least in the Southern Tier I'm
trying to push for a third one but
sometimes I get some some negative
negative pushback when I try to do
things not in Concord but it's okay
um so I am working on um a space for us
to meet probably in June uh in Greater
man in Manchester or greater Manchester
or somewhere in there and I'm if I do
one more it'll probably be either the
Seacoast or Cheshire county Sullivan
County that area
um so if you have somebody that wants to
spearhead uh Cheshire county or the
Seacoast I know those are two vastly
different things um but if you have
somebody that wishes to spearhead that
please let me know um because it's just
one less thing that I have to do
um
I I will take care of Manchester
um because that's where I live
um
that would be wonderful if you could yep
um if you absolutely could that would be
great thank you
um
the way I see the bills we have in front
of us
um so we have this one from DHHS which I
think we'll discuss here in this work
session with these changes that they've
made we have the
um we have SB 170 which I think we have
some let's call it issues we have to
work out with with the grandfather in
claws
um and then we have SB 221 which is a
study committee so I will kind of do the
opening Salvo on what I think is the
easy one which is the study committee
um I I will not be supporting the study
committee
um not because I don't believe the
things in their value
um just because I believe that this I
believe this special committee is
accomplishing those goals
um so and that's not a attack on the
sponsors it's not attack on their
intentions I think it was well
intentioned it was introduced obviously
before the sub this special committee
was formed um so it wasn't like they
were trying to usurp us or any of that
sort of stuff but I do view it as an
opportunity as I kind of said in our the
work section that I opened and closed
which is we have a bill that I believe
is at this point unnecessary
um and if we do have something that we
have heard from him in a listening
session or our two or three meetings
that we wish to introduce we have a
vehicle that we can do it um it would be
a non-germaine Amendment obviously but
at least it'd be relative to child care
so I view that bill
um I view that I view SB 221 as that as
our opportunity to do something
um if we so discover in this next work
session to do something to that bill
originally it was my intention to do
that to 170 because I thought that that
was going to be a little more of a
consensus but it was like with anything
the more you started to pull on it the
more you started realizing that's not
the bill to go touch
um and the good news is SB 221 land in
their lab so that's kind of the world as
I see it right now with our legislation
in front of us
um the upcoming meetings that we'll
actually have in Concord we're going to
do one on the quality Care Program
um I'm I believe I've released research
documents to the committee in regards to
that we did hear about that in the
listening session in North Conway I
think there's opportunity there but
there's going to be ruffled feathers
there
um but I do recommend that you read the
I believe we I believe our committee
researcher released I want to say five
or six research documents that I asked
her to compose one of which was about
that program another thing to convey to
the committee which I know we have heard
about is the child care scholarship and
the change that I went in so DHHS put in
a budget request to move to the
enrollment based system there was a
legislative bill in the Senate I believe
it was 237 227.
um the Senate has the sentence in
possession that we're not getting that
but it is I did explore that because
that was a legislative action to try to
get to the enrollment based model and
DHHS filed a budgetary action to get to
that so I did have in the documents that
released you to check to make sure that
dhh just can do that with a jowcar
change and it appears so so that is kind
of the the good news is we don't have to
vote on that um our friends in jail car
are going to get to vote on that and our
friends in the budget which I somehow
get the feeling that representative
walner may have had a hand in that uh
say nothing
um
but um so that's I guess a good news
there is that we won't have to touch
that in this committee I believe it was
uh I want to say it was it represented
water was a 10 expansion was it going
from 75 to 85 percent and then moving to
the enrollment model it was both of
those or was it just the moving to the
um
you can't print your microphone on first
person the enrollment piece which the
um pay by enrollment which the
department had in their budget uh
raising the eligibility for family
assistance from for a scholarship for um
from the present level which I can't
even remember what it is up to 85
percent of median income
and the other is to pay providers at the
75th percentile of the market rate or of
a cost analysis which would be done by
the department yes
so as you can imagine as somebody who is
business accepts that scholarship I was
super excited not to have to sign a
conflict of interest paperwork on that
so
um
so that's kind of um that's kind of a
big check mark right there
um that um that my largest concern to
the Committees I did spend a significant
period of time making sure that because
I was a little bit confused because the
Senate was taking legislative acts in
um and then when you go and you read the
actual statute that governs that program
it's actually a very wide gives DHS a
very wide
um uh
latitude to conduct that program
basically the language says the
department will conduct a program to the
benefit of child care the child care
system in the state of New Hampshire
that's effectively what it says it's
it's very open-ended so um you know um
good news if you wanted that change bad
news if you don't like open-ended
bureaucracy uh either way it's getting
changed uh assuming job car passes it
and the budget doesn't pass and the
budget passes and then job car passes it
so I guess you know we're going to have
to pass a budget um
um so uh good news on that front anyways
um in that case I want to open it up to
the first thing I do is let's kind of
knock out the things that I've talked
about here in sequential order
um
assuming we find something in our
conversation that's about to take place
uh is anybody
really opposed to that change if we even
find a change that change being put onto
a replace all with sp221 is anyone is
anyone opposed to that off the bat or is
that just uh it's obviously not a
dictatorship so I have to if we do find
a change we would do it to 221.
uh yes representative climbs
um
I meant that I find
a very creative solution here in 221 and
I think it's worthy of this group kind
of taking that on as one of our tasks to
do these hearings
um specifically regarding the municipal
property tax exemption so I would like
to actually notice and have some kind of
a listening session as a committee on
that specifically and commit to doing
that if we're going to use this as our
placeholder Bill to do other things with
uh you have my you have my firm
um any other comments to that that idea
if nobody objects to it I'm going to
assume it's it's an okay idea and I
won't they won't sharpen the pitchforks
and light the torches on me uh
representative page I I agree that it's
the better vehicle if there's something
we want to do this year
um partly because I really support 170
and I want to keep it clean yeah
um and I
second representative McWilliams on on
the um
Municipal property tax exemption piece
um and seeing if we as a committee can
can investigate that more seriously and
I would love if we could get minutes
from that Senate conversation it sounds
like
the
um the um there were some very specific
questions and concerns which seemed very
easy to chase down answers to if they
are limited to what was what was
presented in testimony so I'd love to to
dig in
okay
um any other just this kind of like this
is the easy one right so I'll get the
before is everybody going to that lunch
by the way you know you get some it's a
freelance overdose Steakhouse I hear
steak tips can be very nice
um all right so we're all we're all
we're all on board with that right we're
all good with that I'm not gonna it's
not gonna be like a mob waiting for me
okay all right so we'll we'll put that
one aside
um
let's say let's just save the the worst
one for last I think um let's just go
right into
um uh not 170 but 94.
okay
um trying to find my notes on 94 here
remember we do have um executive session
and work section notice now next week so
if we don't find consensus today it's
not the end of the world it's okay
um but it just kind of gives us the
opportunity to substance things out and
if we do need to make an amendment it
does get us time to get that Amendment
ready
so
um I guess I'll uh where
where I know it's on where's the I'm
looking for my sorry I'm looking for my
markup copy of one 94 and there it is
all right
okay
um so let's talk about 194. does anybody
kind of want to do the opening um
someone whenever I know uh
representative McWilliams you had some
issues with the definition of child you
I want to commend the sponsor and
everyone who worked together to put this
um as a piece of legislation forward uh
the the only change that I'm proposing
and I have already sent a proposed
amendment over to OLS is on page two
line one section one I'm just going to
read out the amendment that I sent over
to OLS child means any person under 21
years of age or up to the allowable age
under doe statute 1102 if the person is
receiving special education or special
education and related Services as
identified by the child School District
I'm looking at DHS they're giving us a
thumbs up on that so I'll tell you what
uh representative if you could put me as
a co-sponsor on that I'd appreciate it
well so and uh you went on there as well
representative decent money all right
absolutely well there's ten of us who
can all we can all sponsor we could all
do it um let me know I'm going to send
an email
um okay
um and then representative page you had
actually concern that I had which is the
elimination of this Wilderness Camp I
imagine it's probably more relevant for
you up in Conway than it is me in
Manchester we have a different type of
wilderness
um but I wanted to kind of get your
thoughts on it I can say that I lived
there I've lived there for 10 years I
think it's I'm I'm comfortable with the
change having heard the rationale in
testimony okay if it's not if it's not a
category that's being used at all then
why retain it yeah I think my the only
question I would have is that when was
the last time it was used
um but if it's not
um you know speaking as to my
constituency we don't have any
Wilderness camps although I do represent
Manchester's only state park just fun
fact Smith Ferry Crossing you wouldn't
know you wouldn't know it existed unless
you lived by it which I do
um
I you did not you did not know it it's
yeah and you can't here's the best part
you cannot park there to get there um
you can only if you live basically on my
street only if you live there can you
get there because there's no parking
yeah
yeah we will never tell you the secrets
of Ward 9.
um
okay um does anyone else have any
questions comments concerns opening
Salvo yes representative Nelson thank
you Mr chair
um I do have a a question maybe um some
people have had more experience in this
um than me might be able to answer
um in regards to
um specifically the
um
affection uh that pertains to the
recreation camp
if there is a complaint of
non-compliance
and these generally aren't year-round so
would there would there be an like
expedited procedure for
taking care of something that might be
out of out of compliance or a complaint
um
I think that's a question for uh for
Miss Clement who I uh
I think she signs those letters or at
least her staff signs of letters on her
behalf
all right thank you Mr chair
representative committee
um do you need me to State my name no
you're fine no it's work session I know
it's a little different we know who you
are um thank you for the question so
anytime we receive a complaint we
respond as quickly as possible we don't
wait on that so if we receive a
complaint that occurred after Camp
season is over we do still contact
relevant parties whether it's the person
who made the complaint to us we'll talk
to them we'll talk to the camp we do
what we can when Camp is not in session
if it's a complaint regarding the
physical space that's obviously a little
more difficult if they're not operating
but we do follow up with the program we
follow up with all relevant parties and
conduct our investigation in that manner
if there's something that's egregious
and you know in week one
um and there's only 12 weeks of that
camp
um would it be something that would
I don't mean to say that every complaint
isn't important but given that the the
length of time that that kids will see
there
um how is that handled I guess we would
always go out there when we know that
Camp's in session so if we get a
complaint in week one and we know we
know what weeks they're operating we
ensure that somebody gets out there so
that they can do the investigation thank
you I appreciate it
what are the questions from his Clement
um probably something that I noticed in
here is you know it allows them to show
up unannounced which sort of 24-hour
program but there's no way to get around
that you have to be able to show up
unannounced uh I just had this like it's
like is this person going to be out at
three o'clock in the morning but I I
highly doubt that so it might like in
the first course like in first
legislative brain I'm like should we
restrain that I'm like no we're not stop
don't go down that path don't go down
that path sorry it's just these are the
things that go through might be typical
now yeah that would be yeah it was like
that juice is not worth the squeeze
um
so uh any other questions from his
Clement while we have or um anything
specifically about
um
other than the one amendment that
represent McWilliams can report anything
else on SB 94 before we start arguing
all right thank you Miss Clement um all
right so gonna put SB 94 aside for next
week
um and we'll um Mr McWilliams when you
get that and I guess I'm on it so I'll
see it too but when we get the finalized
version of it we'll circulate it to the
committee because uh we will do that all
right so now let's talk about fire codes
all right sb17 sb170 who's excited
okay
um so I'll kind of give uh chair usually
goes last but I'll kind of give my
opening thoughts on this um we need to
need to need to bring
when you find a way to bring this into
law that we all are comfortable with
um it definitely needs to happen IT
addresses the number one problem uh with
we haven't the state of New Hampshire
now which is supply for child care
supply is number one problem
um
so there are legitimate I think there
are legitimate concerns with um fairness
and safety
um uh speaking personally I I have issue
I always take issue not just with child
care but with everything I do
legislative of rules for thee but not
for me
um it's just kind of a general guiding
principle that I have
um so I do take issue with um
grandfathering some and then not
allowing the others so my personal goal
is that we could find a way to marry
those two in
um and I think represent Warner I think
you hinted at something which should be
instead of beating up the licensing
requirement looking at the fire code
requirement which is definitely outside
of our scope at least am I putting words
in your mouth I don't want to put words
in your mouth if I am doing that but I
think that's what you implied
it was just a question yes okay it was a
question it was an implication
um
but I do
I I do have physics because it does it
does raise the question which is there's
38 centers that's what we heard right
who fall who would be grandfathered and
that's what we heard 38 centers so it
does raise the very legitimate question
which is
if it's not safe why are these 38
centers allowed to do it right so um and
I get that their grandfather and I
totally I totally get that but like okay
so what's what's the deal then like if
there's 38 they're getting grandfathered
Nelson you're more than welcome to speak
when I was
drinking that out there to them
um
so Sean to me on the State Fire Marshal
I get what I want to I guess reiterate
is that there's really there's no
grandfather on the fire code so the
centers are safe right so they're
inspected periodically by the fire
officials and is licensed by the um DHHS
um through the licensing program
the way I picture the grandfathering is
it's administrative process on some of
the name changes stuff
um so the
the group daycare Family Day Care all
those different terms are a little bit
clunky right now between the State
Building Code the state fire code and
DHHS language and we're trying to clean
that all up which I think this bill does
a great job at
um what the bill also does is in the
fire code
um we look at those so small centers
Under 12 can be in a home or outside of
a home and still be called family group
daycare they can beat a small under the
as Deputy Katie mentioned like the three
to sixes or up the seven to twelfths
under DHHS rules currently those little
centers are something else when they go
outside into a business or something
like that so we're trying to that's it's
it's I know it's muddy right it's it's a
the really the intent of 170 is to try
to clean this all up and make it easier
I would almost beg you not to try to
change the fire code because then we'd
also be trying to change the State
Building Code too right now the same
building code and the state fire code
are really close and we've worked really
hard over the last few years and
representative Williams has been part of
some of those conversations through Edna
um we're really trying to minimize
conflict with the codes to make it
easier for the consumers whether it's a
small business owner or a developer
architect engineer designer whatever
design professional they are it's we
take National codes building or fire and
hampshireize them a little bit through
the respective processes get them uh
ratified through the general court and
we've done a great job at
we got a little way to go but we've done
a great job to clean those up over the
last five years or so I'd hate to try to
muddy the waters so we're we're taking
some rules in some other statute
language that's not in alignment and
trying to align it is really what I I
see this as doing I I want to repeat
myself
the the centers are safe they're being
inspected I'm going to say though
there's some places in the state that
maybe they're not getting expected quite
to the level they should be and we can
help them do that and make sure they are
truly safe but the structure of the
codes is in place new or existing to
make sure they meet our our current
building and fire code so I there I
would really the grandfathering is is
not safety related from the code
perspective it's a DHHS grandfather not
it's more administrative
grandfathering is the way I that's the
way I've gotten it in my head to try to
I don't like grandfathering either so
um there's no one existing in my world
and you meet one or the other
um and and I will say if there's unique
circumstances on the fire code
me being the State Fire Marshal has the
authority to issue a variance under
specific circumstances if there's other
Provisions that provide a degree of
safety some equivalency so we have some
options if we have some of those weird
situations
um that they would come to my office
we'd process them go visit the site I
was at one in in Lee just the other day
that's
um we're working with the operator to
make sure it's it's been operating for
probably 30 years-ish
and we we're going to let them they're
going to make a few minor changes and
they're going to be allowed to operate
the way they are under a variance I
appreciate that clarification I think
that did help me representative someone
you had a question
thank you yes I do I I just want to be
clear so existing
currently existing licensed
centers
are in compliance with
the the state fire codes supposed to be
supposed to be so as far as I know thank
you
as far as I know there could be there's
there's
so why are we grandfathering anything
because it's a deal it's a dhh
administrative I see thank you because
we're changing some names right so we're
changing some names of some things in
yeah it's trying to catch up with all of
that is really I'm hearing some yeses
behind us yeah yeah they were giving the
thumbs up when I said it's a thcs
grandfather and they were super excited
that they're like representative you're
welcome
um
that
or
so I would stick to I just want to read
this here I would stick to the the
numbers of six and seven to twelve and
things like that for alignment
um I'm gonna just I'm gonna phone a
friend in the back because I wasn't part
of this original striking part of it but
um
my concern I think is that if we
unstrike something it's gonna
go back to not aligning well with what
we're trying to do
um does that make sense I I think the
concern of the committee not to speak
representation but to try to speak
verification is that if we if we don't
unstrike that our representative's point
is we unstrike it and put in a thing
about so long as it complies with the
state fire code right that's what you're
for DHHS for thhs uh and I think it's I
think that the sentiment is the
sentiment is that it's at least speaking
personally is I'm fine if they're if
they're misaligned to the extent that
we're not choking the supply that's safe
right so if it's to represent
Christian's point if it's in alignment
with the state fire code I'd rather
unstrike it put in a closet it's got to
comply with the state fire code
regardless of the number if it's
misaligned and not cut off that support
potential Supply
um I I think is that that's that that's
my feeling on it I know just may not may
not like that as much because it is
misaligned but I I I I am I'm gonna have
I want to pass this I really like I
really really do I am going to have
problems choking any Supply down right
now
um especially in the current situation
I think one just
trying to name things the same in
different places
um I think it's important because for
years
before I had this position I worked in
Concord as an inspector for a long time
too and trying to figure out okay I have
dhhs's form that I have to sign off as a
fire inspector this place is safe right
I know the fire code I've been working
on it and living in it for a long time
but okay is this a daycare occupancy or
is this a daycare home or is this a
daycare center or is this like so as a
Fire official and I think even for the
operator it's confusing right I have I
have this form that says this I'm
calling the fire chief said I need to
get a sign off on this and I'm sitting
here scratching my house as a Fire
official saying
hmm I know if it just simply says
compile with the state fire code it
would make sense
but then I need to know what I mean
people they're going to put in there
right so if it just says Cloud plot
comply with a state fire code I go to
say the Opera how many people are going
to do I'm going to do 12. I'm going to
do 20. okay I'm going to open my book to
the chapter I'm going to go through my
chapter I'm going to say yup yup yup you
made all these things comply with State
Fire code
but then they're going to go to the
licensing facility and say
um I want this number of people in the
in the this the numbers are different
right so I'm going to go just real quick
example we saw the liquor folks out in
the hallway before we got here right and
we overlap with them a bit right so we
issue places as places of assembly
permits by law and the we've worked
really hard with them too to make sure
that the numbers the number when they
need an assembly permit to issue a
liquor license the stuff matches as best
as it can be so when I'm always I heard
O's right when O's looks for Concord
fire to issue the place of assembly
permit they know 100 people they need us
they need a permit we were the cogifier
rates department they send the liquor
and they get their liquor license and
it's pretty smooth and I think that when
I see Family Daycare home means this and
then I go to the fire core and Family
Daycare means the same thing that's a
win right if
and if it's I don't know if it's I I
would refute that notion it's not a win
if it constrains the supply of child
care
accessibility
for the purpose of making things the
same name I would my personal preference
and I totally hear what you're saying um
Marshall yeah and and I get it but it's
it comes the argument that I believe is
being bestowed is that it's it will
confuse people less when they're trying
to start their Center but I would rather
there be some confusion and allow them
to have 15
um then just cap them down at 12 when
they can safely have 15.
um because it's just we're just not in a
situation in the state right now to cut
any supply of child care if they can
safely be in that home and that's 13
right I don't want a waiver issued I
want it to be by right I don't want it
to be
um and and I get I get the alignment
argument I totally get it it's it's
would be less confusing you are 100
right I just don't think it's worth it I
I rather there be some confusion and
have more
supply of child care because you know we
could have that argument in five years
if the market had stabilized
um and then maybe be like yeah but we
are we all agreed like in the opening
style that we're in a crisis right now
that moms can't find cares for their
infants and the idea that we're going to
potentially limit the supply
um
so that things can be not as confusing
it just it just doesn't the art it's
just I get the argument it's not it's in
a valid argument to make it's just the
the good doesn't outweigh the bad if you
see what I'm saying oh yeah I get you I
guess I'd ask maybe Melissa to come up
and talk about the specifics of the
different license categories because I
think that
um
you know one of the things that
we can almost put a daycare is in a
bunch of different places right it's
just a for us it's the numbers we need
those thresholds as I think as you are
alluding to right if I have a hundred
people in a space versus a thousand
people in the space there's going to be
different requirements right if I have
uh
um a daycare facility that's a wood
frame building like our typical homes
and you're on the first floor you're
probably fine but when you have a
three-story wood frame building you're
putting your kids on the third floor we
want it to be different because it's
going to take longer you know longer for
them to get out and the fire is going to
move rapidly and things like that so we
we just need those different thresholds
to help Define the all the requirements
um yeah if I just responding real fast
then I'll let you hear um and I I don't
speaking I can't speak the entire
committee but I don't think anybody up
here would agree with anything you just
said
um I I think our disagreement would be
just using DHHS to cap them down if if
you use the fire marshal say hey this
isn't safe you can't do this even though
the DHHS license allows for it
you can't do it it's not safe and nobody
appears nobody here I I can't say nobody
up here is going to disagree with you
right
um but if the fire if it is safe for
them to be in there to cap down the DHHS
license
for the purposes of alignment just seems
it it just doesn't see it just doesn't
sit well with me anyways representative
you want to go and I had to get that off
my my brain before but thank you no I
guess my only question was in my
understanding of what this bill is
intending to do it's intending to open
up more buildings that are already you
know commercial and probably are already
Meeting those higher requirements so I
guess I
don't see it as super concerning I see
so if I could just propose splitting you
know finding some Middle Ground here I
think we can probably find Middle Ground
if we were to keep in the two stricken
pieces we would be calling a family
daycare home and I think Melissa
probably will come up for this
discussion but I want to get your take
on it before you leave the witness stand
we would be calling Family Daycare home
six children with the ability to flex to
nine so when you're doing your
inspection for a family daycare home
you're inspecting for nine occupancy and
then you would be saying family group
daycare home would be 12 children with
the ability to flex to 17 so your
inspection is 417 children does that
make sense to you would that be sort of
a logical way to do the checklist yeah I
mean for us it would be looking at is
the Family Daycare home in the group
daycare home would be just a little bit
different for us that's all that's
really what it would I mean from a fire
code official that's
that's what it would be like if we were
at 17 I think I heard it would be uh it
would be a daycare occupancy not a not a
daycare a home per se that's all
right in our world change the definition
of family group daycare home 12 with the
ability to flex to 17. right so that the
fire inspection is for 17. right under
the category of a family group daycare
home
I I let the HHS figure out the naming of
them your inspections you could have a
checklist based on those occupancy
numbers yeah it would still be okay and
if they don't meet 17 they may only end
up at 15 and that's what they're
licensed for and everyone agrees that
although the statute may allow them to
go up to 17 their property doesn't allow
that due to other constraints and so
they're only licensed up to 15 and so
it's really 12 but they could Flex three
more under their conditions okay all
right I think that there's a way to make
this work
representative
at 17 as the family child care provider
flipped over into an area that is a lot
more restrictive
so that they're now meeting them having
to meet the requirements as would a
center with 50. yes so yeah I mean
there's a couple of I mean the hard part
with the codes right is there's a lot of
like what-ifs and exceptions and things
like that but um the you know you're
looking at maybe a sprinkler system
depending on where and how the
building's constructed and uh what level
the floor what level what floor level
they're on maybe a fire alarm a
commercial fire alarm system like we
have in this building not the you know
in a home we're just we want smoke
alarms and things like that so that yes
as you there's there's changes that
could be impacted the sprinklers
probably is probably the is the biggest
one we hear when you get into
upper level Upper Floor levels and wood
frame construction which is our the
predominant construction type in our
area
and I think that's a business decision
that that provider has to make and if
they want to put all that in their
locality of municipality allows for it I
just don't want the DHHS license to
restrict it
I have another question could you tell
me how long
has
um this definition
been in place for how many years I on in
on the dhh side each side I have to ask
ask my friends behind me
um the fire code side I would suggest
the stuff hasn't changed in quite some
time
um I could definitely look back but it's
it's been it's been this way for quite a
long time on the fire code
does anyone else wish to lops and bombs
at the fire marshal
it's all good we don't get this very own
all right um with that I think uh
probably DHHS probably wants to come up
and tell us why we're wrong and that's
totally fine it's totally
thank you thank you thank you uh Fire
Marshall
hello again
so
for
our
I'm trying to like encapsulate
everything that I've heard so far and
hoping I'm providing a good response but
obviously feel free to ask me for
clarification so when looking at this
we're asking for changes for family
child care home which is limiting to six
and then family group
the anyone being if we allow this um
exception where the current ones remain
as is and then new people are limited
based on the new statute it's not going
to affect the family day care home that
definition there's no effect because
then if they're being approved for nine
children they're going to be moved to
family group daycare so as the fire
inspectors are improving them their
codes are going to they're going to be
inspected at the same code because
they're looking at 12 and under so
there's no impact to Family Day Care
any impact we might could have would be
family group because they're the ones
who will be capped at 12. the way it
works now is we often have either the
zoning office or the fire inspectors or
the towns and the programs in the Life
Safety Code inspector for the towns are
confused about what they're being asked
to approve because the code says they're
12. they're in a you know they're in a
home dwelling and then our rule says
that this is a family group home so it's
they're looking at a home so it is there
is some confusion and there is things
that we need to walk through for that
there are also
um
so I mean that was to speak to that part
of it is that we're trying to make this
process as smooth as possible because
that is where the confusion comes up I
had mentioned to representative Walnut
earlier that I would like the ability to
go back and see how many programs that
we have been approving for more than 12
in the recent years because that's
happening less and less often due to
town and local approvals so it seems to
be that's already it's possible that
it's already a constraint currently but
we have so many programs that have been
in existence for so long they may they
because of previous rules they were
allowed to do that so
I would appreciate as the um State Fire
Marshal of State Clarity on this because
it is a process for providers to
understand and they don't understand
right now what it is that they need to
get approvals for and how it needs to be
approved
representative walner
how many how long do you think we've had
this in law
um I know the existence of 170e for
child care that came in around 1990 I'm
going to guess it's about the same time
frame when those definitions were
created I don't have the statute book in
front of me I could refer to that but
it's probably right around in that
um I to your point so you say Family
Daycare home won't be impacted but we
could Impact Family Group daycare home
yep and we currently have 38 that are
licensed and there's fewer of those
coming up
restrictions that are placed because
they're in neighborhoods these are
residential and you said mostly due to
Talent ordinances and it also there's an
um
there's a ratio issue too where you're
allowed you know when your family group
you have two providers there are many
towns that have
um an ordinance where if you're in a
residential area all of your employees
need to live in your home so we've had
people who've been constrained from
becoming a family group because their
worker that was going to be coming they
don't live there so there there are
other things that come into play here
um that are limiting the family group
it's it seems there's already limits
there and we're just trying to align to
make sure the fire inspections that are
being done are the correct ones for the
number of children the location where
they are
we have represent page just to
just to make sure I'm following when we
talk about it being confusing for the
providers what it is they're asking for
um do you think we could be in a
situation where an inspector comes
assuming that the facility is only ever
going to have 12 children in it but that
provider may actually be during the
holidays taking 17 children and they've
only been inspected as though their
facility would never have that that
capacity do you think that that is the
situation that is that the the law is
currently written is actually creating a
problem there
um I I'm hoping that doesn't happen
because the fire inspection has to be
done prior to us issuing the license and
the fire inspector puts the maximum
number of children that is allowed there
so we cannot approve a license that goes
beyond what the fire a fire inspector or
a town has approved them for okay thank
you that's helpful
and your DHHS providers with a list of
towns that do do that restriction I
wouldn't be able to know
um I know that I just saw in the news
yesterday that there's a whole new
zoning map out there I don't know if
they have that was that information yeah
that was for our friends on the special
committee on housing
um but I I think just kind of speaking
out loud I probably wouldn't get
unanimous approval on the uh from the
committee on this but I might sponsor
something that might just supersede that
because that's uh
that's uh well it's not even it's
unfriendly to child care if you're gonna
this I I I I view as you guys know I I
own a license shocker so I own one of
the bigger ones
um I view Family Daycare and family
group daycare home as one of the
immediate relief valves for what we're
experiencing now yeah um this is my
personal view
um and uh if if it's an issue where
towns are going a little overboard on
that um I have no problem trimming back
the towns if it gets more mobs back in
the workspace to overcome that three
point one or three point nine percent uh
drop off in a woman Workforce
participation rate
um so that's just that's just me
speaking out loud on my personal
opinions I wouldn't do it to this bill
um because that would be a whole other
can of worms but just you may see that
coming from me in the fall just uh just
an FYI
um
any other um questions before we um I
will probably have five minutes of
committee talk and then we'll I'll
recess and we'll go over to those and
get some steak tips
uh any questions for Miss Clement
thank you all right thank you um does
anybody have any any of the committee
members have any thoughts they wish to
share
okay great uh all right um we I will uh
I'll see you guys next
um next Wednesday at 10 A.M I'll look
forward to the amendment from
representative McWilliams
um and I will probably bring forward an
amendment
um to bring back the language
um
and we can discuss it I'll probably
bring forward two amendments oh I'm
sorry you're fine we're not adjourned
you're fine just make sure you press the
silver button okay so um for those of
you who I don't know I'm Dorian Shockley
the manager of the Bureau of Licensing
and certification at the department and
I just want to clarify something because
I mean everything that you're mentioning
is very important
um if we were to unstrike I just it's
been in existence since 1991 but it's
not what's happening in practice and I
think that's the distinction that's not
clear
um when we don't give a license based on
our rules we give a license based on
what the locals approve for the
occupancy and the locals are approving
to the revised language if they're not
they're not allowing those three or six
or extra if the if the code doesn't
require it so I think that's a
distinction that needs to be really
clear this this amendment these changes
are actually not only aligning our rules
with the codes but they're now putting
into practice the reality of the
environment so I think that's an
important distinction that I think the
committee needs to know
all right
um well on that bombshell we'll close
the uh we'll close uh the um the work
session and I hope to see as many you
over at O's as possible and you see me
running over there next
it's actually Hotel Concord just to be
clear Hotel Concord which is actually
thank you
foreign